All right,
so this was the definition we saw at the end last time after I'd read it a bit
larger,
I just repeats the second of those definitions.
This is the definition that can mix the notion of evolutionary stability for now
in pure strategies with Nash equilibrium.
And basically it says this to check whether this strategy is evolutionary stable
in pure strategies.
First check weather s hat s hat is a symmetric Nash equilibrium.
And if it is,
if it's a strict Nash equilibrium,
we're done.
And if it's not straight,
it's,
that means there's at least another strategy that would tie with asthat against
us hat.
Then compare how s hat does against this mutation with how the mutation does
against itself.
And if s hat does better than limitation than limitation does against itself,
then we're okay.
All right.
And one virtue of this definition is it's very easy to check.
All right,
so let's,
let's try an example to see that
and also to get us back into gear and reminding ourselves what we're doing a
bit.
All right.
So in this zone,
Paul,
just sort of trivial game,
but still game looks like this.
All right.
And what asked,
those were asked the question,
what is evolution?
Realist stable in this game?
So no prizes for finding the symmetric Nash Equilibrium in this game.
Shouted out what?
The symmetric Nash Equilibrium in this game.
Hey.
Okay.
So Aa ae is estimate trick,
Nash Equilibrium.
It's easy to check.
So really the only candidates for an evolutionary stable strategy here is a,
alright,
so the second thing,
that's second thing you would check is,
is a strict nash equilibrium.
So what does strict Nash equilibrium means?
It means that if you,
if you deviate,
you do strictly worse.
All right.